I think actually lots of people in the
Muslim community I gave an address to
them as in Council of Britain last year
at one of their annual dinners I think a
lot of people are actually doing that
already and seeking to marry up and
illustrate how Muslim values are
actually British values are to be
realizing I'm not sure I would use the
word patronizing for the simple reason
that I haven't actually read the letter
but you and I can have this debate if
you want but the wider and more bigger
issue for us is how do we ensure what
you are you Muslim people may be trying
to come back on in half an hour's time I
mean it doesn't take long to read the
letter and then we'll have this
discussion patch with them and I think
you all might be I think you're being a
bit ridiculous right now and your eyes
can form their own that your viewers can
form their own views I was asked to come
and speak about David Cameron's speech
on the economy and what was happening
around the labor market nobody told me
that I was going to become come on to
this program and asked to agree with I
thought that the government was
patronizing Muslim people and Muslim
leaders I'm not just going to speak off
piece without actually having read a
letter I don't think you're being
terribly fair your peers can make their
own sense you get the party line right
okay well we'll have to end it there as
shadow business XIV thank you very much
indeed